golden knights owner bill foley has been
really busy not only trying to get his
team back on the ice but
buying into a gaming business sports
director chris matthews caught up with
the night's owner joins us live in
studio with a bit more
yeah bill what a great guy fun to talk
to this guy wherever you meet him
talking today from the island of kauai
actually over in the islands
he's excited about the acquisition pay
save which includes gaming
and says it might be his best investment
ever pay safe includes gaming and a
digital wallet that will
not only allow gaming but other services
as well we also spoke to foley about the
nhl's return to play the target date is
january 13th
at t-mobile arena it'll be a 56-game
season it doesn't know
if there will be no fans some fans or
perhaps more fans
but there will be multiple games played
in las vegas not just the knights also
contrary to reports in canada guess
who's not being shopped around
and foley is bringing another franchise
to las vegas he speaks to it all
and again if you think of it the sharks
they're they're going to be playing in
san jose anytime soon the kings aren't
going to be playing in
la any time soon and they're probably
the same with the ducks so
they need to come here tsn up in canada
had the story that
uh the golden knights to free up some
cap space or
shopping max pacharetti no we're not
shopping taxes uh
we are we do have cap issues and so
some of those things have to be resolved
as we go forward we start getting into
the season but
he definitely is not being shocked and
i've
i'm working on an indoor lacrosse team
to come to las vegas which would start
playing in the
new henderson arena probably in 2023 so
i'm thinking small time chris i'm not
going big today
all right he's not going big time this
time we'll have more with the knights
owner coming up at six o'clock he has an
idea
for an app he reveals the idea to us and
then he kind of regrets it because he
says
someone's going to steal his idea denise